[Music]
okay we just watched John wit three
again kind of glad I did though it stood
up to multiple viewings do you think oh
yeah yeah like I said I mean there
wasn't really anything else playing that
we wanted to see and yeah we were just
like well yeah we we need three movies
this weekend I really like strongly
freeze on lifeless yeah see that one
again yeah music was good notice like
more stuff in it once you've seen the
story you can kind of relax for the
second viewing you just kind of relax
and just roll with it and just watch the
choreography in the gunfights and just
to kind of enjoy the the visuals because
it is a pretty movie
yeah the shot compositions are just to a
point I mean every single one of them
that scene when they're in that damn
glass tower fighting their way up to the
top all the kungfu you know that martial
arts all the all the LED visual visual
effects on the back of huge screens
there they look great look great yeah I
just liked it and I think I mentioned
this I don't think I mentioned this on
the first review but I said this is one
of the very few action movies that I've
seen that actually incorporated
reloading oh yeah firearms well yeah
this with the fight choreography which
you don't see in a lot of action movies
but I really like the way they
incorporated it and it was very fluid
and I've heard that there's that there's
videos of Keanu Reeves on YouTube yeah
he training he live-fire trained yeah
yeah yeah he's good with guns eating
riding motorcycles he makes motor he's
got a company that makes yeah I picked
up a lot more this time this time around
like there was a couple things that I
should be spoiling this it's like we
didn't spoil it a first year but
sometimes on the second reveal
if I put it in the thing but I was there
was a couple of things that happened in
the first book that I kind of missed
because I guess I missed a one or two of
dialog or something like that so I
picked it up a lot better than this
the second time and it was also like a
lot of callbacks to like characters
doing things that like other characters
at the beginning of the movie so it was
like a lot more yeah cuz I think I'd the
first review I said it was just like one
big long fight scene which book but
there was like actually a lot more yeah
I was watching I was going man there's
not an ounce of [ __ ] soy in this
movie and then she goes to a sushi
restaurant and a guy the sushi chef
makes her Blowfish Blowfish very deadly
no soy I was like yeah there's no
[ __ ] soy so they're dropping hints of
the movie
no soy in that movie I liked it but yeah
if you haven't seen it go see it to get
moving yeah making all the money and
well yeah and it's like this it's been
out for a week or something like that
it's like the middle of the week if we
came to see it it was still still packed
so yeah and I think that some of the
people in there looked kind of familiar
and I think maybe they saw I'm almost
gonna say it's as good as it's the first
one if not maybe a little bit better I
don't know it's hard to say I'm getting
hard to radom and actually I liked it
better I mean I really liked the second
one too but I think this one's better
than the second one I'm gonna say this
one's as good as the first one yeah and
a little bit better than the second one
although I like the second one they're
all really good they're all really I'm
going to see what they're gonna do next
I know I'm hoping there's it there's
like a really bad it's like that's not a
spoiler it's a really bad cliffhanger at
the end so I got a feeling that John
wick four will be chopped wick for Baba
Yaga
that's all things because if you don't
know it because you have this one which
is called Parabellum look up the latin
and see what that means and
what direction for war prepare for war
but I think it's about Baba Yaga I think
that's I think it will be your probably
will confront me
you
okay just got done seeing Aladdin had
what's his name Will Smith Will Smith
yeah he played the genie and it was
live-action version as opposed to the
cartoon one that they used to have and
it was good man it was really good I
mean it's been a long time since I've
seen an audience actually clap when the
movie was over remember they were
clapping in there it's kind of reminded
me of the old Sinbad movies like seven
voyage of Sinbad and golden had that
vibe where there was some good action
and adventure and kind of sinister
béziers that were [ __ ] you know
sorcerers and good magic effects but
then it would go into comedy and romance
and it was a musical imagine if Sinbad
was a musical but we're talking the
story of Aladdin costumes really good
sets really good you know I think a lot
was all CG but it just looked like you
know pre-islamic Arabia you know with
Sultan's and [ __ ] you know it's just
there's good movie I liked songs
everything Will Smith knocked it out of
the park he really did no I mean I
really liked it too it's I remembered
because remember when we did the thing
we did the live-action Dumbo and I said
it had been so long since I had seen the
animated one now I remember the animated
Aladdin a lot better than the animated
Dumbo this one is pretty much beat for
beat the same although all the songs
except for I think they added one
because they flushed out Jasmine's
character a little bit and they added a
character of her she had a handmaid
named Dahlia so she's that I don't think
that was in the in the cartoon they but
other than that it followed pretty much
the same thing Will Smith did a really
good job as the genie actually he did
some of the same gags as Robin Williams
did like you know especially when he's
like turning yeah when he's turning
Aladdin into Prince Ali the effects are
phenomenal they really are very I mean
some of the set pieces I mean obviously
even from my favorite part of the
cartoon was the Prince Ali song and that
whole thing where he first comes into
agribon with all the elephants and
always like you know holy [ __ ] and
everything and that was also the
highlight of this movie too but there's
like a lot of really really good yeah
and I'm faxing this it was like super
cool looking and the songs are fun it
was just like a fun I could say I could
tell you this is gonna be for many kids
who saw this and you know young people
that are seeing this growing up Will
Smith's gonna be remembered for this
that role they did some of the same
stuff that Rob Williams did like in the
cartoon but live-action no yeah well
Smith's foot is kind of a spin on it and
I think they I like I said the look of
it is
I think really the first part of it was
I'm not gonna say it was slow but they
were just like setting up the characters
but I mean once Goldsmith came in as the
genie that was just kind of like yeah I
liked it it started off like a Sinbad
movie for me you know I mean he did some
cool [ __ ] and everything and there was
some paranormal stuff and caves and you
know Fosters and [ __ ] they changed a
couple yeah great great for a general
audience you know not I mean everybody
loved it I you know I was having fun I
was everybody's laughing and people
clapped at the end of it a long time
okay yeah we just got done see him
bright bird it's good [ __ ] movie all
right it's a very simple premise what if
Superman was bad it's not Superman
basically it's that same story
Superman's origin story like he's an
alien that came from space but and was
raised by a simple farm family right was
a bad guy yeah cuz you know that puberty
kicks in and all of a sudden you know
that goes the crystal calling him you
know and all that kind of [ __ ] out in
the barn and then you know he's getting
messages to take take over Earth and
he's already he's not a human and he's
got weird tendencies you know kind of
like a psychopathic serial murderer and
that started all starts coming to the
forefront and how scary would that be
because this kid is absolutely
unstoppable you're talking about
Superman he reminded me this is kind of
like yeah it's like if Superman was evil
across with the kid that could wish
people into the cornfield I like that
yeah it's like everyone's like scared of
pissing him off and stuff like that
this was actually like I was expecting
this to be pretty good but I actually
like this much better than I was
expecting one thing about it I really
liked the couple like the kids parents
the kids Brandon they were very you know
likable very believable yeah they were
trying to deal with it and there's just
how are you gonna do with that that's
what I mean and they did and I like they
they didn't really make any stupid
decisions did like everybody in this
movie did right much of what it thought
a normal person would do in the
situation and they talked the way a
normal would talk so you didn't get a
thing like that really briskly paced
yeah really really good Gore in this
yeah this be honest let's be honest if
something like this had happened it'd be
hopeless there be no stop and yeah and
there's some kind of inhuman about him I
mean there was times where I thought
here start eating people which I think
he was tempted to eat people that in
some of those scenes
and it is it isn't it's creepy it's not
a purse it's not a person you're talking
about it's an invasive alien species
that has urges to just take over
everything you see humans as bugs you
know already man
eventually that's when that change
started having it it's like you know you
guys are bugs basically yeah you know
and never silly things there were some
things that he did and I thought he was
gonna start eating some of the people
but because never can't split cast boy
yeah because like I said one of my
favorite parts about I mean there's a
lot of good parts about this but I
really really liked all that in some way
what I liked how it ended I really liked
how it ended it delivered on all fronts
not an ounce of [ __ ] soy in this not
an ounce of soy and something like this
could have legs I mean I wouldn't
surprised if I saw you're gonna try and
make a franchise man Hado they're
[ __ ] stupid I feel like they're
setting up they are stupid because when
I first saw the previews for this I
thought is this like a dark DC no you
know like [ __ ] horrible somebody just
ran with the premise what if an alien
came to earth like Superman did and that
yeah right and there's no hints that
there's any kind of superheroes and I
hope there isn't because it's better
when there's just don't [ __ ] it because
cuz that's it because you're talking
about a horror movie this is not a
superhero movie or a super villain movie
this is a [ __ ] horror movie yeah so
if you don't like horror movies yeah
you're probably not gonna I mean this is
a straight up in a way to take on Jason
he was invincible yeah kind of it's just
on a much bigger scale yeah it's like
Superman like The Twilight Zone kid
splasher yeah but yeah I I ended up
liking it I recommend it as a good blue
like I said it's only short there's an
hour how long we face no you didn't even
walk around it's you know yeah Scott's
for me for me the length was perfect it
didn't need anymore
yep that's it that was good movie real
good
[Music]